la parole est à notre collègue philippe
dominati pour le groupe l'est
républicain et pour deux minutes mon
cher collègue
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur car deux jours après les
attentats du 13 novembre
une jeune femme courageuse n'écoutant
que sa conscience a appelé le numéro
antiterroriste 297 pas son geste et l'a
probablement sauver d'autres vies
empêchant un triple attentat et surtout
en permettant à la police de neutraliser
l'un des assassins du 13 novembre
cette jeune femme attendent ils de la
part de l'état soutient reconnaissance
assistance et surtout la volonté de tout
faire pour mieux réorganiser sa nouvelle
vie aujourd'hui elle se sent abandonnée
elle est néanmoins dans la nécessité de
prendre un nouveau risque en contactant
un certain nombre de médias le président
de la ligue des droits de l'homme pour
faire part de son isolement
comment en est on arrivé là alors ma
question est simple comment l'état
peut-il se déshonorer dans une situation
pareille et j'attends évidemment que le
ministre puisse me répondre sur la
parole et au ministre de l'intérieur
bernard cazeneuve pardonnez moi de vous
le dire de façon aussi claire monsieur
le sénateur mais faire des polémiques
sur des sujets aussi graves
alors que les informations qui sont
communiquées par voie l'instant sans
dans leur intégralité totalement fausse
totalement fausses en pleine crise
terroristes ne me paraît pas être à la
hauteur de ce que nous devons faire
collectivement je vous le dis très
franchement et je vais aller plus loin
je vais aller plus loin le
la police a sous l'autorité du procureur
de la république
deux jours après les attentats procédez
à l'interrogation de cette personne il
l'a fait sous l'autorité du procureur et
il ne l'a pas fait sous x pourquoi pour
des raisons qui tiennent aux droits on
ne peut interroger sous x qu'une
personne dont on est convaincu au moment
où elle interroge qu'elle n'a aucun lien
avec la faire la personne a été à la
demande du procureur de la république
interrogé sur le régime de la garde à
vue
premier point deuxième point après qu'à
un certain nombre de journalistes étant
informé de cette affaire ont pris
contact avec mon administration nous
avons mis en place un ensemble de
dispositifs extrêmement précis pour
protéger cette personne et j'ai une
connaissance extrêmement fine de ce que
nous avons fait à ce moment là pour en
avoir été informés et avoir moi même
demander sa protection la plus absolue
des journalistes l'ont interrogé
nous leur avons indiqué qu'il était
extrêmement imprudent de procéder ainsi
parce que sa vie risquer d'être mise en
danger et que les informations qui
étaient diffusés ne correspondaient pas
à la réalité et malgré tout cette
interview a été diffusée
le procureur de la république a décidé à
ce moment là d'enclencher l'action
publique pour mise en danger de la vie
d'autrui et cette personne ne pouvait
pas se voir reconnu à ce moment là
nous falloir conclure le statut de
témoin et toutes les protections qui s'y
attache tout simplement pour des raisons
qui tiennent au fait que le droit ne le
prévoit pas j'ai donc décidé pour
conclure d'adresser au procureur de la
république une lettre extrêmement
précises dans laquelle je rappelle tout
ce que l'état a fait pour protéger cette
personne et je considère que ces
polémiques sont totalement indigne
monsieur dominati monsieur le ministre
je comprends votre gêne et on voit
parfaitement que la notion de polémique
est très mal venue il s'agit simplement
d'honneur et de respect de la parole
donnée à une citoyenne qui a permis le
renouvellement d'attentât et les bons
policiers comme les bons ministre de
l'intérieur à ma connaissance on
toujours préserver et protéger les
citoyens qui permette l'arrestation de
criminels et j'espère que vous aurez
honneur à tenir compte de cette
interpellation au nom de mon groupe pour
que faire en sorte que non seulement ce
dispositif puisse dans l'avenir
continuer à être performant vous
concluez également à ce que faire en
sorte que cette personne soit protégé
considéré comme il se doit
enfin monsieur le président comme au nom
de mon groupe
non je voulais simplement au nom de mon
groupe souhaiter beaucoup de bonheur et
de sérénité aux membres du gouvernement
qui peut être dans quelques heures ne
seront plus en fonction
ceci est le message est passé